the mini cow clip has reached more
people I am getting I told you I am
getting more messages from people about
the mini cow clip it's [__] bananas
woo mini cow train and most people are
like you know those are just baby cows
they're not mini no there's also a mini
cow yes but also most of the mini cows
have some sort of growth def yeah or you
could get a cow with Down
Syndrome it doesn't mean has many cow no
but they're they're they're they're
smaller or dwarfism that's what I meant
yeah two different things sorry about
that do cows get down syndrome probably
I've seen like I've seen a cat with Down
Syndrome a cat yeah there have animals
with the syndrome Google
Google Google
Google do pets get down syndrome do
animals get down
syndrome I don't I can't remember I was
about to say I can't remember seeing one
but I don't know if they look different
do you know what I mean and how would
you know if your cow had downon
technically dogs and pets or Tech this
says dogs technically dogs cannot get or
have Down syndrome however they can have
conditions that present similarly dogs
may also inherent other genetic
disorders or chromosome abnor
abnormalities but research does not
indicate that dogs can have Down
syndrome as people can what about other
animals do animals get down syndrome
while some wild animals can suffer from
similar C Chrome oal defects they cannot
have Down syndrome as it is specific to
humans there have been several cases
where animals have similar symptoms to
Down syndrome and people mistakenly
assume it's the cause do me a favor now
now Google animal Down syndrome
images animal
down I wonder if the if it if the
animals that are affected with whatever
they're affected by look different yes
look different they do they do yeah this
is a this is a tiger with that
get the [__] out of
here what let me see that honestly first
of all that looks like a tiger from
Harry Potter find me another
one this is by the way animals with Down
Syndrome is not a rabbit hole I thought
we were going down on this podcast this
is an arut
tank just looks like an arut tank yeah
kind of yeah albino gorilla okay but
that that albino gorilla doesn't mean
Down syndrome does it yeah it does
that but that that this is fascinating
to me it's fascinating look at these
giraffes come
on the one with his tongue out get the
[__] out of here by the way that's a
long ass tongue man dude giraffes have
super long tongues you don't know that
yeah I think I do have you ever fed a
giraff yeah at the at the laou there's a
lion let me see that picture again I'm
just going to show see that picture he
could join it on the fun that that photo
is crazy yo this looks straight up like
a crackhead this looks like I feel like
we should put that on a T-shirt and like
looks like crackhead line I I want to
put it on a T-shirt and the caption is
going to say this is how [__] up I
want to be tonight dude this looks like
4day Bender somebody just asked me hey
you want to hit that you want to hit
that again and I'm like Yo dude this you
send that to me yeah I'll send it to you